movies with a low rating on Rotten
Tomatoes are common but to get a zero
percent rating takes a certain kind of
awfulness sure it's usually not the type
of perfect the filmmakers were going for
but to get any kind of perfectly
unanimous response on a film is quite a
feat though watching a bad movie on
purpose can seem like a complete waste
of time some of these just have to be
seen to be believed
find out how things can go so wrong so
fast with these critical bombs you
should watch anyway Manos the hands of
fate it's one of the best episodes of
Mystery Science Theater 3000 and one of
the strangest films of all time from the
beginning everything about Manos the
hands of fate was a bad idea how Warren
told Oscar winning screenwriter sterling
silicon that making a movie was easy he
figured it was so simple he bets olifant
that even he a lowly fertilizer salesman
could finish a picture when your grand
artistic vision stems from winning a bet
you're already off to a bad start so
Warren raised $19,000 from friends and
family and started filming mono he
crafted a complicated story about a
family that gets lost on vacation and
stumbles upon a cult leader that tries
to turn all the women in his family to
its table of bickering bride you are
troublemaker you deserve to die it could
have been something simple but it wasn't
Manos is definitely not a cash grab
instead it's a bizarre expression of art
though everything about it is strange
there did seem to be some attempts at
making a real film at the end of the day
Manos is a movie about a real family
coming together giving their all and
trying to make art no matter how
low-budget or strange roller boogie this
disco infused rollerskating rec was
supposed to be a breakout role for
Exorcist alum Linda Blair if you wanted
to get as far away from her Exorcist
casting as possible the idea of doing a
harmless rollerskating picture doesn't
sound like a bad idea right
not okay maybe it was a bad idea
unfortunately everyone hated the film
and it did little to lift her career
Roger Ebert wrote I didn't think it was
still possible in the dog-eared final
days of the 1970s to have this silly
innocent lame-brained and naive movie
the fact that the film contained all
disco music which was fading in
popularity didn't help matters
van ado came out the next year just to
double-check that the nation was truly
over roller dancing yeah we were over it
heart beats I'm here to tell you about
this new movie it's called heartbeats
and it's about me and my pal Andy
Kaufman and Bernadette Peters star as
few robots who were created to be human
companions when they meet each other
they fall in love and run away which is
kind of cute but that's not the whole
story of heartbeat there's also a
tank-like robot called crime buster
who's come to hunt them down a garbage
child robot that Kaufman made from spare
parts and capsule a corny stand-up
comedian robot who served no purpose
whatsoever but believe me folks this
movie's got a lot going for it though
the movie is weird and a lot of the
jokes are hokey what makes it all the
more strange is the robot design Peters
looks like some kind of overly oily
first-generation fembot Coffman's robot
to be a carbon copy of a to tan Chevy
Chase Kaufman appeared in so few films
is worth watching heartbeat for that
alone and it also serves as a warning
that even the funniest people can manage
to make awfully unfunny things
Megaforce Star Wars is one of the most
influential films of all time but one of
the biggest effects of the sci-fi
blockbuster was the crazy amount of
ripoffs that followed in its wake
like the epic failure Megaforce
Megaforce is about you know explosions
and laser guns it's hard to admit but
even after multiple viewings the only
thing from Megaforce that will be mega
impress upon your brain is very
phosphorous booty now that's not to say
this film isn't worth watching the weird
mix of comedy and action plus the utter
lack of a budget make this a pretty
funny watch you won't get some intricate
tale of space intrigue but you will get
to see one of the worst flying
motorcycle special effects seriously who
thought that looks good
plus there's the added bonus barry
bostwick with bleached hair looking like
a rejected giv brother as the New York
Times review of the film flooded the
combination is original just as a peanut
butter and olive loaf and which might be
but it isn't any good staying alive so
you may only remember Saturday Night
Fever for its disco dancing and white
bell-bottoms it's actually a really
great film about lower-class kids trying
to find some good and hope in their
lives as the sequel to Saturday Night
Fever staying alive has none of that
in staying alive Tony Manero has moved
to Manhattan and wants to be a dancer on
Broadway unlike the first film where
Tony is a charming but troubled young
man here Tony is just an all the time
jerk now in addition to the Bee Gees we
get the dulcet tones of Frank Stallone
brother of Sylvester Stallone who
directed the film the dance numbers are
bizarre the leotards are cut high and
the story is just garbage
but it's great garbage Mack and me
another film from the rip-off Department
this degrade et has the double
distinction of trying to capitalize on
Spielberg's incredibly successful film
and being a great excuse for blatant
product placement max stands for
mysterious alien creature and it turns
out that coca-cola not Reese's Pieces
pleases this alien although Mac is way
more fond of product placement than his
field virgin counterpart a whole scene
is devoted to a birthday party held at
McDonald's set features Ronald McDonald
himself and enough of the chains logos
to fund the production company's next
five knockoff there's also a dance
number which et is notably lacking so at
least one thing was different
[Applause]
[Music]
seriously it just goes on like that
another reason to see this one almost
every time Paul Rudd goes on Conan to
promote a film he switches out the clip
of his own movie with the same clip of
Mack at me Rudd has done this for over a
decade and for some reason it never gets
old
Simon says simply watching assignments
oi light up for an hour and a half would
contain better acting than this Dennis
Rodman equal the original entitled
double team featured the bad boy
basketball player and jean-claude Van
Damme teaming up to kick butt and give
horrible line reading their styles are
different very different for the sequel
Van Damme did not return so they got the
next best thing
Dane Cook the movie has a lot of close
comedy and plenty of Rodman looking cool
while super fake explosions happen
behind him the film is a great reminder
of a time when Rodman was a really big
deal 1999 feels so so far away
Pinocchio if you want to see the second
worst film of all time sit down for a
terrible evening with Pinocchio
no not the Disney version the 2002
Roberto Benigni vehicle after winning
two Oscars for life is beautiful America
was charmed by this excitable Italian
and couldn't wait for what wonderful
film he'd bring to us next unfortunately
the next film he brought was this one
it's odd enough that a 49 year old
Venini decided to play the small puppet
child but the American version had to
make it even weirder instead of dubbing
the film with paninis accented voice in
English Breckin Meyer of roadtrip Fame
was chosen the 30-something voice of
Meyer coming out of the nearly 50-year
old body of Venini is simply disturbing
plus the fairy tale film has a good
moral they know to a film where you play
a ten-year-old if you're pushing 50
ballistic x versus sever now it's true
that all these films have a zero percent
rating on Rotten Tomatoes but the crown
of worst of the worst have to go to
ballistic experts is sever a lot of
films that reach this level only have a
couple dozen review
since there are fewer critics chiming in
the odds of a perfectly bad score are a
little better but X versus ever was a
major relief and a lot of critics agreed
that it deserved the ultimate F 116
critics to be exact they all agreed this
movie was garbage it beats the next
worst movie by almost 50 critics ouch
what makes this film so hated critics
seem to agree that the movie has a
convoluted plot no character development
and a ton of messy looking explosions
that all just blend together after a
while
still it's worth watching just to see
what Rotten Tomatoes considers the very
worst of them all thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to